I've said before the United States
cannot and should not intervene every
time there's a crisis in the world so
let me be clear about why we must act
and act now when we face a situation
like we do on that mountain with
innocent people facing the prospect of
violence on a horrific scale when we
have a mandate to help in this case a
request from the Iraqi government and
when we had the unique capabilities to
help avert a massacre then I believe the
United States of America cannot turn a
blind eye we can act carefully and
responsibly to prevent a potential act
of genocide that's what we're doing on
that mountain and therefore authorized
targeted airstrikes if necessary to help
forces in Iraq as they fight to break
the siege the Mount Sinjar and protect
the civilians trapped there already
American aircraft had begun conducting
humanitarian air drops of food and water
to help these desperate men women and
children survive earlier this week one
Iraqi in the area cried to the world
there is no one coming to help well
today America is coming to help